el primer voto fue emitido aquí por un
francés de 90 años este colegio
electoral de san pedro y miquelón una
pequeña isla frente a la costa de canadá
tuvo el honor de iniciar la segunda
vuelta electoral en francia sobre todo
si es cierto que eso significa que hay
que esperar un poco más hasta que el
resto de francia vote pero somos los
primeros en hacerlo así que estamos
contentos más al interior del país en
montreal las colas daban la vuelta a la
cuadra y continuaban dentro en el centro
de convenciones de la ciudad en esta
urbe unos 67 mil ciudadanos franceses
están registrados para votar pero en la
primera vuelta sólo el 35 por ciento
acudió y es que la abstención suele ser
mayor entre los 1.4 millones de votantes
de ultramar no obstante miles cumplieron
con su deber cívico creo que aunque no
vivamos en francia es importante mostrar
con la pequeña influencia que tenemos
los valores que son importantes para
nosotros teniendo en cuenta las
diferencias horarias las embajadas y los
consulados de todo el mundo se
convirtieron el sábado en colegios
electorales a veces en lugares lujosos
como en buenos aires y en nueva york' a
veces en escuelas transformadas para la
ocasión también se abrieron los colegios
electorales en los territorios franceses
de ultramar en el caribe unas 600.000
personas estaban llamadas a votar como
aquí en guadalupe
este año es único porque es la primera
vez que vota una sensación de presión
porque es como si el futuro de francia
estuviera a nuestras manos
después de américa los colegios abrieron
en los territorios del pacífico y del
océano índico donde algunos se sienten
olvidados es una pena que los candidatos
no hayan hablado muchos de los numerosos
territorios de ultramar porque hay mucha
gente que vive aquí en nueva caledonia
hay más de 240.000 personas censadas
pero como aquí enumera la participación
puede ser menor esta vez ya que los
independentistas llamaron a boicotear el
voto